foreign
[Music]
cancellation day we turn to New Jersey a
state that is always perpetually
canceled simply for existing but you
know the state's general crappiness and
the fact that the whole place smells
like a poorly maintained Burger King
restroom is incidental um for our
discussion today new jersey.com has a
story about a former public school
teacher now suing the school that she
says drove her to quit after shaming her
for having emotional breakdowns in the
classroom a lot going on here let's
start at the top says a former teacher
in the South Orange Maplewood school
district has filed a lawsuit claiming
that she was forced to resign after
transfer to teach special education
without an aide caused her to have
crying spells in the classroom Sarah
Barlow 34 of West Orange said in court
papers that she was teaching
kindergarten at South Mountain
Elementary school during the 2020-2021
school year when she was abruptly
transferred to the district's Annex
school to teach a different class Barlow
was asked to teach a classroom that
included special education students yet
she was not provided any special
education teachers or paraprofessionals
to assist her according to the suit
filed December 22nd prior to a trans for
Barlow had disagreements with school
principal Kevin Mason over the handling
of two troubled students according to
the suit
all right well so far it seems as though
Miss Barlow has legitimate reasons to be
frustrated she was pulled out of her
class thrown into a more difficult
situation without proper supporter
resources assuming of course that her
version of events is correct and I have
no reason to doubt that it is after all
it all sounds haphazard inefficient
self-defeating
which is exactly what we've come to
expect from the public school system and
if this is where the story ended then
she would have my sympathy but
unfortunately it keeps going and my
sympathy quickly evaporates continuing
this situation caused Miss Barlow a
significant amount of emotional distress
and exacerbated her anxiety a condition
she has suffered with since her teenage
years the suit States on October 24th
Mason sent Barlow a letter admonishing
her for exhibiting signs of anxiety and
stress in the classroom the suit said
Barlow alleges that her symptoms were
caused by not having an aid and by
Mason's alleged mistreatment in this
letter Mason stated that Miss Barlow's
crying spells were unprofessional and
stated that a corrective action would be
forthcoming the lawsuit says that
Barlow's therapist then placed her on a
six-week medical leave due to the Stress
and Anxiety that she was experiencing at
work
okay so she broke down in tears in front
of our students multiple times and then
took a six week vacation to work on her
feelings
sorry it wasn't a vacation it was
medical leave because in our insane
culture we use the same language to
describe a woman taking a break from her
work because she was anxious
as we do to describe a woman taking a
break from work because you know she
needs a heart transplant
but it gets better listen uh it says
quote unfortunately due to the
district's failure to address her
complaints of unlawful behavior and
complete disregard for her disability
and mental health Miss Barlow was forced
to resign from a position on November
1st 2022 the suit States the lawsuit
says that Barlow's anxiety which
requires medical treatment is a
recognized disability under the New
Jersey law against discrimination in
addition Administration administrators
in the South Orange Maplewood School
District failed to accommodate Barlow's
disability disciplined her for her
symptoms and failed to include her in
the discussions about reasonable
classroom accommodations the suit says
okay
so to use a phrase that I hate
um there's a lot to unpack here first of
all you know I do hold men to a higher
standard of stoicism
than I hold women to
um as as as men we should be expected
even more to Bear difficulty and
hardship without complaint this capacity
is one of the things that makes a man
valuable to his family and his community
it's what makes a man a man
and it's why men who cannot carry their
burdens with silent dignity are so
incredibly useless and such a strain on
everybody around them
and also really unappealing to women
because it's the last thing that they
want
now women are more expressive more
emotive more empathetic by nature which
is why we have we have and should have
greater tolerance for their emotional
displays but that tolerance only goes so
far because whether you're a man or a
woman
if you're in a position of leadership
especially if that leadership position
involves caring for and educating
children
you need to be able to handle stress and
frustration and setback without making
it everyone else's problem
women have a greater compulsion to share
their feelings with those around them
which is usually fine if they're sharing
their feelings with their husbands or
their friends or their family or trusted
confidant
but the children in your classroom are
none of those things
let's hope
uh they are not going to school in order
to be sounding boards for your
frustrations or to validate your
feelings
your responsibility is to provide them
an education one that is unburdened by
your emotional baggage
if you can't do that or you won't do it
then you shouldn't be teaching
I mean I don't care what you've been
through in your life I don't care how
difficult your life is or has been
sometimes in life it is it is your
responsibility to suppress your feelings
the feelings you have about those
difficulties and carry on like nothing
is wrong
I know that's a shocking thing to hear
these days people here but yeah there
are plenty of times in life where no
matter what you're going through it is
your responsibility to deal with it and
shut up and do your job
it's what's expected of you
you know the doctor who's performing
brain surgery on you he might be having
a bad day also
but you'd be very concerned if he came
into the room right before they put you
under sobbing and crying and complaining
about his anxiety disorder
and that's because in his capacity as
brain surgeon you expect him to do his
duty and to subordinate his feelings
whatever he's going through you expect
him to just deal with it and get the job
done like a professional
you would expect that of your heart
surgeon your brain surgeon your your
airplane pilot
um really anyone else who's performing a
job that you need done
you would be annoyed if you ordered a
pizza and it came to your house late and
the reason it came late is because the
the pizza delivery guy is having a
really bad day and and you know
struggling with his feelings that would
annoy you and it should
because you're you're here to do a job
but your job is to bring me the pizza
and in that same way you know we expect
you to do your job as well
and again if you can't do it there's
always the other option which is to
which is to not if you really can't if
you can't do the job then don't do the
job leave the job
if you're there people expect you to do
it it's that simple
second Point anxiety is not a disability
it is not a medical condition no matter
how often this claim is made no matter
what the psychiatrists say no matter the
billions of dollars of pharmaceutical
companies are able to make off of it
anxiety is not a disease it is rather
just one of the tolls we all must pay
for the privilege of being human
there's nothing strange or unique about
the person who experiences anxiety
there would be something quite strange
about the human the human being who did
not experience it but no such human
exists or has ever existed
of course the medical industry will
claim that what I'm talking about you
know when I say everyone experiences
anxiety what the medical industry says
is that well that's just regular anxiety
that's average anxiety that's that's
anxiety in its normal amount
but when anxiety reaches beyond that
threshold that's when it magically
becomes an illness
as medically valid as diabetes or
Parkinson's or the flu
who decides what qualifies as normal
anxiety who determines where the
threshold is who gets to declare what
what amount of anxiety we're supposed to
have
well coincidentally enough the people
who have drugs to sell us they get to
decide
and they're the only ones who can decide
by the way indeed if you as a human
being
dare to speak about anxiety which is the
most ubiquitous of all human experiences
and if you dare to speak about it as
someone who is not selling anything
someone who doesn't stand to profit off
of your position on the subject that
somehow makes you less reliable
the message is clear when it comes to
questions of supposed mental illnesses
the only trustworthy people are the
people who are financially incentivized
to come up with certain answers
this is all nonsense of course questions
about the nature of anxiety and what we
should do with anxiety and how much
anxiety a healthy person should
experience
these are philosophical questions These
Are Spiritual questions
they're questions that defy simple
medical analysis
questions that cannot be reduced down to
formulas or solved merely with
prescription medication
and the problem is that the spiritual
authorities the priests and philosophers
of our day are the people who put the
title doctor in front of their names we
have long since given them authority
over not only strictly scientific and
medical questions but deeper questions
about the very purpose and nature of the
human person and about the meaning of
life and how life is supposed to be
lived and how people are supposed to
feel and and and and and all of that
we've done this partly because we've
been duped and we do this partly because
we prefer the fiction that these people
are selling us
because it lets us off the hook
it allows us to claim that we have no
control over our emotions
we can't be blamed for how we behave
and now it even allows us to claim
disability and take six weeks of medical
leave because we're feeling stressed out
that's what Miss Sarah Barlow is up to
and it's why she is today finally
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
shows and move over to the members block
if uh you want to become a member you
can do that now by using Code wall
should check out for two months free on
all annual plans hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]